as our nation struggles to confront
racial inequality artists are of course
also trying to come to terms with it all
and America's inaugural youth poet
laureate is one of those artists Amanda
Gorman captured this pivotal moment in
an original poem she performed it for
our cameras at the cross colors exhibit
at the California african-american
Museum in Los Angeles
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you will be told this is not the problem
not your problem you will be told that
now is not the time for change to begin
told that we cannot win but the point of
protest isn't winning it's holding fast
to the promise of freedom even when fast
victory isn't promised
meaning we cannot stand up to police if
we cannot cease policing our imagination
convincing our communities that this
won't work before the work has even
begun that this can wait when we've
already waited out a thousand son
by now we understand that white
supremacy and the despair it demands are
as destructive as any disease so when
you're told that your anger is
reactionary remember that rage is our
right it teaches us it is time to fight
in the face of injustice
[Music]
[Applause]
not only is anger natural but necessary
because it helps carry us to a
destination our goal has never been
revenge just restoration not dominance
just dignity not fear just freedom just
justice the greatness of America is the
right to protest
[Music]
whether we prevail is determined not by
all the challenges that are present but
by all the change that is possible and
while we are unstoppable if we ever feel
like we might fail if we be fatigued and
frail when our fire can no longer be
fueled by fury we will be fortified by
this faith found in the anthem the vow
all black lives matter black lives are
worth living worth defending worth every
struggle we owe it to the Fallen to
fight
[Music]
but we owe it to ourselves to never stay
kneeling when the day calls us to stand
together we envision a land that is
liberated and not lawless we create a
future that is free not flawless over
and over again and again we will stride
up every mountainside magnanimous and
modest we will be protected and served
by a forest that is honoured and honest
this is more than protest it's a promise
that's all we can all do when someone
says something that powerful just once
again Amanda Gorman is echo she always
does knocks it out of the park she
always seizes a moment and puts it in a
way that is very unique to her also
shout out shout out shout out to Kris
bender who produced that piece and Brian
Cunningham who edited I say this all the
time those pieces are very hard to do
that way yep Amanda Gorman just never
ceases yes